Okay, back to our list again.
Hopefully, now you've
created your action sheet and
implemented the method,
Launch Photo Library.
So, your app might look
something like this.
Here's the action sheet.
And here, I press Choose from Existing,
and I'm able to choose this video.
I took this video where I'm
pretending to squish my coworker.
And then,
just like with the newly recorded video,
I can see my GIF in the GIF editor, and
I have the option to add a caption.
So, convert a video from the photo
album into a GIF, checked.
We're getting to the homestretch.
We just need to enable some simple
editing to improve GIF composition,
namely, we're going to allow the user to
trim a video before it's converted into
a GIF and
constrain the GIF to be square, so
that it doesn't get distorted.